[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui deux ex états
soviétiques qui se livrent depuis
quelques temps une guerre économique et
diplomatique sans merci se sont
l'ukraine et la biélorussie
critique menacé accusations mutuelles le
regain de tension on promet de s'étendre
dans toute la région quel est donc
l'état actuel des relations entre
l'ukraine et la biélorussie début août
le président biélorusse accuse son
homologue ukrainien de mener une
politique menaçante à l'égard de la
biélorussie kiev voir en alexandre
lukashenko le principal responsable de
la dégradation des relations les
attaques verbales ne cesse de prendre de
l'ampleur depuis près d'un an les lignes
politiques divergentes à l'international
ne font qu'aggraver la tension entre
kiev et mims l'ukraine perçoit comme une
menace le rapprochement entre la
biélorussie et la russie de son côté
kiev co perd de plus en plus étroitement
avec l'union européenne les états unis
et surtout le temps plusieurs exercices
militaires conjoints ont lieu en ukraine
cette année pourtant l'espoir d'une
normalisation n'est pas totalement
écartée le cash enhco refuse de
reconnaître le rattachement de la crimée
à la russie et essayer de maintenir la
neutralité au sujet de la guerre dans le
donbass
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici une brève
présentation de ces deux états frères
slave née de l'éclatement de l'urss
c'est le blitz deuxième pays d'europe
par sa superficie le cren s'étend sur
plus de 600 mille kilomètres car elle la
biélorussie quand elle est de taille
plus modeste avec environ 200 mille
kilomètres carrés en ce qui concerne
leur population la différence est encore
plus importante l'ukraine compte plus de
40 millions d'habitants pour moins de 10
millions en biélorussie au niveau
économique qui aiment domine toujours
avec un pib d'environ 155 milliards de
dollars contre 60 milliards pour son
voisin du nord république semi
présidentiel l'ukraine est dirigé depuis
2010 9 part volodymyr zielinski ancien
acteur producteur et humoriste la
biélorussie quand elle est une
république présidentielle avec alexandre
loukachenko à sa tête régulièrement
réélu à la présidence du pays depuis
1994 sur le plan extérieur le cren s'est
résolument tournée vers l'europe et les
états unis et manifeste son souhait de
rejoindre le temps l union européenne
depuis le coup d'état de 2014 la
biélorussie pour sa part chercher
jusqu'à récemment à diversifier ses
partenaires mais après une escalade de
tension avec le et les états unis à la
suite des élections présidentielles de
2020 lukashenko se rapproche de plus en
plus de la russie
l'ukraine et la biélorussie vivent
actuellement la pire période dans leurs
relations bilatérales c'est du moins le
constat du président biélorusse
alexandre loukachenko selon lui le
principal responsable de cette
dégradation est le pouvoir actuel
ukrainien qui selon lui s'ingère dans
les affaires internes biélorusse kiev
pointe du doigt à loukachenko l'accusant
de prendre des mesures anti ukrainienne
l'autre facteur qui empoisonne les
relations bilatérales est une vision
divergente de la politique
internationale alors que minsk maintien
des liens étroits avec moscou kiev
cherche à se rapprocher de bruxelles et
de washington ce qui irrite surtout le
gouvernement biélorusse et la
coopération croissante de l'ukraine avec
la pologne et la lituanie deux états
avec lesquels la biélorussie a des
relations tendues ces derniers temps les
exercices militaires réguliers que les
deux états mènent avec leurs partenaires
jette de l'huile sur le feu alors qu'est
ce qui est à l'origine de cette
dégradation des relations bilatérales
par quoi se traduit la confrontation
entre l'ukraine et la biélorussie
quel avenir se profile pour les liens
entre les deux voisins pour répondre à
ces questions nous rejoignons françois
achevant si général expert en analyse
géostratégique messieurs chavancy
bonjour bonjour
selon alexandre lukashenko les relations
biélorusso ukrainiennes sont
actuellement dans leurs pires étape
pourquoi en est on arrivé là je
relativise ray est ce que ce sont
vraiment des relations très détériorée
j'ai quelques doutes néanmoins est ce
que nous n'assistons pas plutôt à un
positionnement de politique intérieure
ça c'est le premier point deuxième point
l'ukraine il faut le reconnaître est
plus proche de l'union européenne que de
la biélorussie et donc de la russie je
pense que ces rapports ont d'un malien
et 3 régional entre d'une part le bloc
malheureusement il faut le répéter de
l'ouest et une certaine forme de bloc de
l'est mais je shove ans y pensez vous
que deux partenaires si proche
économiquement et culturellement puisse
se permettre une confrontation de longue
durée je crois qu'il faut aussi
relativiser ce point
l'économie biélorusse est différente de
l'économie ukrainienne elles sont en
revanche complémentaires
donc effectivement il y aurait une
complémentarité à développer mais le
régime politique d'une part les rapports
politiques au niveau régional font que
effectivement ce relations économiques
sont faibles et on ne voit pas trop
d'ailleurs quels sont les accords
économiques que qui pourrait se
développer aujourd'hui entre les deux
états quelles sont les conditions selon
vous pour que normalisation soit
possible entre l'ukraine et la
biélorussie dans un avenir proche je ne
sais pas si peut y avoir vraiment
un rapprochement de meilleurs rapports
il faut bien voir comme que l'ukraine
est orienté vers un positionnement
démocratique proche de l'union
européenne la biélorussie ce n'est pas
tout à fait sa situation cette situation
c'est d'un état autocratique qui veut
garder sa souveraineté qui veut garder
sa sa liberté d'agir mais reste comme
cela des ford ans d'un grand voisin qui
s'appelle la russie dès lors que la
russie et l'ukraine ont quelques
rapports tendus il est certain que nous
ne pourrons plus rentrer dans des
rapports bilatéraux entre la biélorussie
et l'ukraine mais dans des rapports de
force qui sont régionaux ce qui change
complètement la donne et retire la
capacité d'initiative des deux états
vous pensez que le cren
n'est plus interdépendantes avec la
russie du coup elle est complètement
indépendante vis-à-vis de son voisin
le cren pour l'instant est en situation
à la fois politique économique délicate
donc vis-à-vis la biélorussie je ne vois
pas trop les liens qu'il peut y avoir
entre les deux états actuellement vu le
contexte géopolitique m'attend si la
question que vous posez ce un rapport
est la russie c'est une autre question
est ce que c'est bien ça que vous
évoquez oui je parle bien de
l'interdépendance avec la russie je
parle du gaz principalement oui tout à
fait le problème aujourd'hui l'ukraine
le dit suffisamment forts notamment avec
la construction ou la mise en service
bientôt de nord stream 2 d'il ya des
redevances et royalty qui vont échapper
à l'ukraine elle a besoin de cet argent
pour son économie ce n'est pas tout à
fait le cas de la biélorussie qui par
contre bénéficie d'une vente privilégié
de d'énergies fossiles notamment du gaz
et qui lui permet d'être a fini raffiné
et d'être vendue à l'export avec de gros
bénéfices voyez la situation économique
est totalement différente entre les deux
états ont une biélorussie économiquement
avec une progression de croissance
économique et une ukraine qui est en
difficulté économiquement parlant
merci beaucoup monsieur chevance y est
nous allons poursuivre notre analyse
tout de suite mais nous vous
retrouverons à la fin de cette émission
pour plus de détails sur ce thème merci
encore le cred et la biélorussie
continue de s'échanger des attaques
verbales le 5 août durant une réunion
sur la sécurité aux frontières le
président biélorusse alexandre
loukachenko s'en prend à son homologue
ukrainien l'accusant d'être à l'origine
de la dégradation des relations entre
les deux états
mais le gouvernement de l'ukraine
poursuivant une voix antipopulaires
appris l'orientation de l'affrontement
sa politique est basée sur la
confrontation et pour nous c'est une
menace supplémentaire que nous n'avions
pas auparavant
kiev ne reconnaît pas à nous cacher une
qu en tant que président biélorusse et
le considère comme coupable d'une
profonde crise postélectorale en
biélorussie
la crise qui a commencé après les
élections présidentielles ne peut être
résolue que par des moyens démocratiques
mais alexandre loukachenko n'a pas eu le
courage de les appliquer
le scrutin qui avait donné largement
vainqueur alexandre loukachenko n'a pas
été reconnue par nombre d'états
occidentaux y compris l'ukraine
arrestations des candidats d'opposition
bourrage des urnes répression brutale
des manifestations qui eve avance une
série d'accusations à l'égard de la
présidence biélorusse ce qui déclenche
une crise dans les relations bilatérales
les déclarations de la rada suprême
d'ukraine du bureau du président de
l'ukraine du ministre des affaires
étrangères de l'ukraine sur la situation
politique interne en république de
biélorussie la légitimité du président
de la république de biélorussie ne
contribue pas à maintenir la confiance
dans les relations biélorusso
ukrainienne et sont considérés comme une
tentative d'ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures de la république de
biélorussie et selon le dirigeant
biélorusse cette ingérence ne se limite
pas à des déclarations le cash enhco
accuse en outre kiev d'autoriser le
transfert d'armes et de mercenaires en
biélorussie afin de déstabiliser la
situation dans le pays une accusation
démentie côté ukrainien
sa déclaration sur la contrebande
d'armes d'ukraine vers la biélorussie ne
résistera aucune vérification car elle
ne correspond tout simplement pas la
réalité les autorités ukrainiennes
désigne minsk en tant que principal
responsable de la dégradation des
relations est selon kiev les premières
frictions ont commencé peu avant le
scrutin présidentiel
fin juillet 2020 la biélorussie arrête
33 russe présentés comme des combattants
du groupe paramilitaire wagner 28
d'entre eux sont accusés par l'ukraine
d'avoir commis des crimes de guerre dans
le donbass kiev sollicite donc leur
extradition malgré ses demandes répétées
minsk les renvois en russie à la demande
de moscou un autre scandale a eu un fort
impact sur les relations bilatérales et
les clac au mois de mai 2021 il s'agit
de l'atterrissage forcé d'un avion de la
compagnie ryanair a exigé par les
autorités biélorusses après
l'arrestation d'un militant de
l'opposition biélorusse qui étaient à
bord romane protasiewicz les autorités
de la république autoproclamée de
lougansk demande l'autorisation de mener
à un interrogatoire de protasiewicz
qu'elle accuse de crimes de guerre dans
le donbass le cash enhco leur donne le
feu vert provoquant des menaces du côté
de kiev
cela fera mal alexandre loukachenko nous
avons suffisamment d'outils pour faire
du mal à des personnes et à des pays qui
ne respectent pas l'intégrité
territoriale de l'ukraine et qui est
venu ne manque pas de recourir à ces
outils fin mai le cren ferme son espace
aérien à la compagnie aérienne
biélorusse bellavia les vols en
correspondance entre la russie l ukraine
qu'assurer la compagnie biélorusse
jusqu'à récemment sont terminées les
vols vers des destinations telles que la
turquie et l'egypte vont désormais
prendre beaucoup plus de temps bellavia
se retrouve au bord de la faillite côté
économique kiev mais fin jusqu'au mois
d'octobre à toutes les importations
d'électricité en provenance de la
biélorussie une me ur tout aussi
sensibles tenant compte du fait que
l'ukraine est le seul acheteur de
l'électricité biélorusse la biélorussie
démarre à son tour une contre offensive
frappant nombre de secteurs de
l'économie ukrainienne fin mais minsk
restreint les importations de certains
produits en provenance d'ukraine
confiserie à base de cacao bière briques
papier hygiénique machines agricoles et
autres pour exporter tous ses produits
le producteur ukrainien aura désormais
besoin d'une autorisation spéciale
délivrée par les autorités biélorusses
alors jusqu'où peuvent aller la
biélorussie et l'ukraine dans leurs
guerres de sanctions tenons compte de la
forte interdépendance des deux états
l'ukraine et la biélorussie sont
d'importants partenaires commerciaux le
volume de leurs échanges commerciaux
bilatéraux attend à l'année dernière
plus de 4 milliards de dollars la
biélorussie représente un important
marché pour un certain nombre de
produits alimentaires et industriels
ukrainiens l'ukraine elle achète près de
la moitié de son pétrole à la
biélorussie les restrictions économiques
de n'importe quel côté risque donc
d'affecter fortement l'économie des deux
pays alors quelles sont les autres
sujets de discorde qui empoisonne les
relations biais le russo ukrainienne
comment l'aggravation des tensions
peut-elle ébranler la stabilité de toute
la région enfin quelles perspectives se
dessinent pour les liens entre les deux
voisins la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
rien ne va plus entre l'ukraine et la
biélorussie quasi absence de dialogue
politique et sanctions des deux côtés
une première dans les relations entre
les deux voisins depuis l'établissement
des relations diplomatiques en 1991
après l'effondrement de l'urss au début
des années 90 la biélorussie et
l'ukraine acquiert le statut de
république indépendante en décembre 91
les deux pays établissent des relations
diplomatiques
l'ukraine devient le premier pays à
reconnaître l'indépendance de la
biélorussie en 94 les biélorusses et les
ukrainiens élisent de nouveau président
koutchma en ukraine et loukachenko en
biélorussie les divergences en termes de
politique étrangère deviennent plus
prononcé la biélorussie intensifie son
intégration dans l'espace postsoviétique
sans pour autant abandonner la
coopération avec l'ue et les états unis
quant à l'ukraine elle tourne son regard
vers l'occident cherchant à éviter la
dépendance vis-à-vis de moscou jusqu'en
2004 les réunions des présidents sont
quasi régulière tant dans le format
bilatéral que dans le cadre des sommets
de la communauté des états indépendants
toujours en 2004 iouchtchenko candidat
pro-occidental remporté l'élection
présidentielle ukrainienne au début de
sa présidence il prend une position
ferme à l'égard du président biélorusse
loukachenko l'accusant d' autoritarisme
or à la fin de son mandat le ton change
iouchtchenko et loukachenko redémarre le
dialogue politique sur fond d'un certain
refroidissement des relations entre
minsk et moscou plusieurs rencontres
sont organisées au plus haut niveau en
2010 c'est viktor ianoukovitch qui est
élu président en ukraine le cap du pays
à l'international change de nouveau les
relations avec la russie connaissent un
certain dégel la coopération se renforce
aussi avec la biélorussie quant à
l'europe le président ukrainien freine
le processus d'adhésion de l'ukraine à
l'ue le mécontentement populaire conduit
à la destitution de viktor ianoukovitch
en 2014 malgré la ligne politique
antirusse du nouveau pouvoir ukrainien
la biélorussie essaie de maintenir de
bonnes relations avec son voisin
méridional cherchant à équilibrer entre
moscou et kiev ce qui permet à misc de
devenir un lieu de négociations sur la
crise ukrainienne le dialogue bilatéral
ne fait que se renforcer sous porochenko
élu président ukrainien en 2014 après
l'arrivée au pouvoir de zelaya ce qui la
tendance continue dans un premier temps
les échanges bilatéraux par exemple
passe de 3 8 milliards de dollars en
2016 à 5,8 milliards de dollars en 2019
en outre les présidents conclut un
certain nombre d'accords dans le cadre
du forum des régions de la biélorussie
et de l'ukraine
tout change elle était 2020 d'abord
vienne l'arrestation et l'extradition en
russie de citoyens russes accusés par
kiev de crimes de guerre ensuite les
élections présidentielles biélorusses
sont considérées comme frauduleuses par
nombre d'états occidentaux et par
l'ukraine les relations bilatérales
entre donc dans une zone de turbulences
où elles sont toujours aujourd'hui le
contexte international ne fait
qu'élargir le fossé entre kiev et minsk
les deux ont des visions divergentes de
leur voisinage notamment vis-à-vis de la
russie si l'ukraine continue de voir
moscou comme un ennemi la biélorussie
continue de développer la coopération
avec elle surtout après 2020 asphyxiés
par les sanctions minsk profit du crédit
russe d'un milliard de dollars pour
gérer sa dette publique les rencontres
russo biélorusses au plus haut niveau se
font de plus en plus nombreuses les
coopérations dans les domaines de
l'économie du renseignement de la
défense se renforce minsk et moscou
accélère aussi le processus de formation
de l'état de l'union entre les deux pays
début septembre après dix ans de
négociations il finalise 28 feux de
route sur l'intégration économique
fiscale gazière et autres bientôt signer
ces programmes ne touche pourtant pas à
l'intégration politique ou militaire et
pourtant ces deux derniers points sont
ceux qui inquiètent kiev l'ukraine y
voit une menace potentielle pour sa
sécurité
nous avons une situation très dangereuse
en biélorussie à notre frontière nord
nous voyons que la russie et la
biélorussie travail de manière constante
à des accords qui pourraient inclure la
défense après cela la russie pourrait
exercer un contrôle sur les forces
armées biélorusse des spéculations
réfutée par mise qui de son côté crie au
feu
face à la coopération toujours plus
étroite entre l'ukraine et le temps
nous ne dramatisons pas mais nous
constatons un fait tout près de nos
frontières l'infrastructure militaire
offensive de l'otan se renforce
méthodiquement
en effet en 2021 l'activité de
l'alliance en ukraine est
particulièrement poussée pas moins de
huit exercices de l'otan sont prévus eux
ont déjà eu lieu cette année aériens
terrestres maritimes il mobilise toutes
les armées et couvre presque la totalité
du territoire ukrainien l'accent est mis
sur tout sur la coopération entre kiev
et ses voisins particulier la pologne et
la lituanie les trois pays même ainsi
l'exercice conjoint trois épées pour
entraîner leurs groupes d'attac
trilatérale en plus de la défense kiev
varsovie est venus approfondissent leurs
liens politiques en était 2020 les trois
pays forment une plate forme informelle
intitulé triangle de lublin en juillet
le triangle si la feuille de route de
son développement avec à l'agenda à
l'intégration économique la lutte contre
les menaces hybride et l'aide aux
aspirations européennes de kiev cette
proximité croissante ne cesse d'irriter
minsk car ses relations avec la pologne
et la lituanie vont de pire en pire les
deux pays sont à l'avant-garde de la
taxe sur alexandre lukashenko après la
présidentielle de l'été 2020 ils ne
reconnaissent pas sa réélection et appui
à la place la candidate d'opposition
souhaite la nati canoë kayak celle ci a
trouvé refuge en lituanie justement qui
lui accorde un statut diplomatique
en réponse lukashenko expulse les
diplomates lituanien de minsk et vilnius
fait de même avec les diplomates
bélarusses entre la biélorussie et la
pologne des incidents diplomatiques
abondent aussi alimenté par des raisons
historiques la méfiance entre la
biélorussie et ses voisins européens
arrive à son apogée cet été en cause
l'afflux sans précédent de migrants vers
les frontières polonaise et lituanienne
que minsk refuse de contenir en effet
cet été le nombre de réfugiés passant de
biélorussie vers la pologne et la
lituanie et explose
mus dénombre déjà plus de 4000 tentative
de traverser la frontière soit 50 fois
plus qu'en 2020 varsovie rapport des
chiffres similaires selon les médias la
plupart de ces migrants viennent de
l'afghanistan et de l'irak pour stopper
l'afflux varsovie et venus commence même
à ériger des murs le long de leur
frontière les deux pays y voit une
attaque hybride de minsk et l'accusant
de fomenter une crise migratoire et
refuse net d'accepter les arrivants mais
la biélorussie ne veut pas non plus les
laisser revenir
c'est une vengeance pour le fait que
l'état polonais et l'état lituanien sont
devenus un refuge sûr pour les
représentants de l'opposition biélorusse
je les dis honnêtement nous n'allons
plus retenir les gens que vous avez
harcelés en afghanistan en iran en irak
nous n'avons plus ni l'argent ni la
force de le faire à la suite de vos
sanctions
misc et qui aiment semble aggraver leur
querelle est pourtant alexandre
loukachenko ne brûle pas tous les ponts
avec l'ukraine sur les sujets sensibles
pour qui m il reste très prudent et ne
franchit pas les lignes rouges 1 ainsi
malgré l'alliance serré avec moscou mais
ce qui n'a toujours pas reconnu la
souveraineté russe sur la crimée et
n'entend pas le faire dans un avenir
proche sur la guerre du donbass
lukashenko maintient aussi la neutralité
il rejette une résolution militaire de
la crise surtout avec l'appui de pays
tiers à la place de la confrontation le
président appelle au dialogue entre kiev
et ses régions tout comme entre kiev et
moscou une position qui laisse une marge
de manoeuvre à la biélorussie vis-à-vis
de l'ukraine la tension reste palpable
entre les deux états mais ont-ils à
volonté d'y mettre fin la réconciliation
était possible dans un contexte régional
si difficile pour y voir plus clair nous
revenons vers françois chossy général
expert en analyse géostratégique
messieurs chavancy commencé dégradation
des relations entre l'ukraine et la
biélorussie peut-elle affecter la
stabilité de la région toute entière
selon vous alors les rapports entre
labiale us ville de russie et l ukraine
se réfléchissent dans un contexte
beaucoup plus large il y à beaucoup
d'acteurs et finalement que ce soit
l'ukraine ou la biélorussie ce sont deux
états qui sont des acteurs entre
guillemets qui deviennent secondaires
puisqu'ils sont soumis aux influences de
la russie sont soumis aux influences de
l'union européenne comprenne aller plus
loin avec les états unis qui
interviennent quand même dans la région
et puis aussi d'autres états
historiquement liés que ce soit la
pologne ou des états baltes donc ce qui
ne va pas bien se passer entre la
biélorussie et l'ukraine aura une
influence régionale mais à mon avis ce
ne sont pas les acteurs principaux d'un
quelconque des règlements géopolitique
de la région quel avenir voyez-vous au
projet d'union entre la biélorussie et
la russie est ce un processus
inéluctable selon vous et dans quelle
mesure l'intégration pourrait-elle se
faire alors la question est complexe ça
fait un certain nombre d'années que la
biélorussie et la russie ont engagé des
accords de plus des 90 1 après années 90
2000 pour essayer de faire une entité
commune de fait ça ne s'est jamais
produit on en a parlé des documents ont
été signés mais à la date d'aujourd'hui
l'un et l'autre ils n'ont pas à denis
fusionner ni créé une fédération la
biélorussie à un cas est un cas très pas
intéressant puisque c'est un cas où un
état de quelques 10 millions d'habitants
veut garder sa souveraineté et ne veut
pas se diluer dans la russie et on voit
bien que la russie par ailleurs ne
cherche pas non plus à contraindre la
biélorussie à la rejoindre mais à
l'inciter à la rejoindre ça c'est le
premier point sur la deuxième partie de
votre question je suis pas certain que
cela se fasse bientôt tout dépendra de
la situation intérieure de la
biélorussie
si la biélorussie n'est pas capable de
résister à ses problèmes intérieurs a
sera peut-être contrainte de se
rapprocher beaucoup plus de la russie
sous une forme qui devra préserver je
pense à souveraineté tant qu'au moins le
double chine qu'aux reste au pouvoir
donc une
une sorte de régions autonomes en
général pas jusqu'à la à la date
d'aujourd'hui il est impensable que la
biélorussie abandonne sa souveraineté à
terme la notion de fédération est
intéressante fédération veut dire qu'on
préserve son identité
ça veut dire qu'on donne un poste
particulier au président de la
biélorussie ou à ces instances
gouvernantes donc si ce travail de
fédérations où chacun est respecté dans
son identité
on posera un projet politique une région
autonome je ne pense pas on reviendra
l'union soviétique et je suis certain
que la biélorussie n'accepterai jamais
et encore moins les biélorusses mais
loukachenko qui subit de plus en plus de
pression à l ouest acceptera-t-il cela
ah non pour moi le nougat shinko veut
préserver sa souveraineté ce problème
c'est qu'il espérait depuis les années
2000 16 une
meilleure relation avec l'union
européenne notamment pour des questions
de financement et d'investissement
autant aujourd'hui vu la situation
intérieure son élection contestée en
la non reconnaissance de son élection
par l'union européenne
maintenant aussi la faire deux mois de
mai 2021 avec quand même l'arrestation
en plein vol d'un opposant tout ceci
fait que le régime de loukachenko est
obligé finalement de se rapprocher de la
russie pour des questions de survie
maintenant jusqu'à ou peut-il aller pour
préserver sa souveraineté et finalement
sa liberté en ce qui concerne l'ukraine
maintenant sa volonté d'adhésion à
l'union européenne et à l'otan at elle
des chances
d'aboutir et que le cren pourrait-elle
apporter à l'union européenne alors il
ya deux points on va régler le problème
de l'otan tout de suite le problème de
l'otan notant ne veut pas de l'ukraine
j'irai aujourd'hui car ça voudrait dire
importer des problèmes de l'ukraine avec
ses voisins et notamment son grand
voisin qu'elle a réussi des toutous les
gouvernants de l'otan disent oubliés
pourquoi pas l'ukraine parmi nous mais
pas maintenant c'est à dire qu'on ne
rejette pas mais on va prendre notre
temps pour éviter d'être engagés dans
des conflits régionaux et peut-être
aussi pour ménager la russie ça c'est
pour l'otan pour l'union européenne
il y a déjà beaucoup de relations
économiques avec l'ukraine l'union
européenne donne près de 15 milliards
par an en dead soit par les banques que
ce soit par
d'autres financements qui font que
finalement l ukraine et déjà
économiquement un an relations avec
l'union européenne maintenant qu'elle
rejoint l'union européenne le prime sera
le même n'oublions pas que l'union
européenne exige pour tout nouveau
membre que des règles soient appliquées
donc tant que toutes ces règles toute
cette réorganisation toutes les réformes
ne seront pas appliquées en ukraine
l'ukraine a très peu de chances de
rejoindre l'union européenne
en revanche il y aura forcément un
partenariat comme c'est déjà le cas
actuellement
merci beaucoup monsieur chemin si je
rappelle françois achevant si général et
expert en analyse géostratégique et est
aujourd'hui avec nous et a apporté son
éclairage dans cette émission cette
partie là n'est pas encore terminée la
semaine prochaine une nouvelle partie
vous attend avec d'autres pions sur
l'échiquier mondial à bientôt sur rt
france
[Musique]